I mean mainstream media has like a seven
percent approval rating in Gallup
Congress has a nine percent they're done
they're a joke why do you call them
mainstream when their ideology is
radical I agree establishment corporate
any of the people dinosaur Legacy dead
media corporate state-run fraud media
[Applause]
oh ladies and gentlemen the corporate
for us is the enemy of the people yes
yes
[Applause]
let me ask all the panel here what is
the proper name of the corporate
prostitute media because there's
dinosaur media Legacy Media the fake
news
the fake News sports stream medium
this is this is what democracy looks
like
all right is it fake news
bad news is it corporate propaganda
is it
it's already collapsed Humanities risers